when you use your body in a certain way
if i sit like this
i'm going to channel i'm going to tap
into a different channel of those waves
than if i'm sitting like this
we took 75 agents randomly
agents said hey do you want to get into
a six-month program to like retrain your
brain your subconscious brain
do it anyway is a mindset trick that you
can use
when you start to feel excuses rolling
up it works a lot like the five-second
rule
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn
how to renew your mind and break your
mental barriers
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one discipline your mind with tony
robbins
these thoughts that we have we think
there are thoughts so it makes it really
hard to change them
and people meditate and try to not think
thoughts show me some of your thumbnails
successfully
consistently if they're full everybody
the mind thinks thoughts
but here's the distinction if i told you
100 years ago we were gonna fly to the
moon and back you would call me a
lunatic that's where the term comes from
people still use it and it doesn't make
any sense because the lunatic is
somebody thought we go to the moon and
back we've done it right
i didn't know that yeah that's where it
comes from that's where it comes from
but if i would have told you
100 years ago that there's going to be a
box in your pocket
and you're going to pull this thing out
you're going to hit a couple buttons and
then
it's going to capture invisible waves
that are drifting around the earth
and bring the waves in and you're going
to see somebody on the other side of the
earth and you're going to talk to them
you're totally nuts thoughts are those
invisible waves
and when you use your body in a certain
way if i sit like this
i'm going to channel i'm going to tap
into a different channel of those waves
than if i'm sitting like this
kind of like a tv set if i turn one
channel it might be a comedy channel i'm
going to see a lot of laughter turn
another one it's a horror channel
turn another channel it's a romance
channel this is what changes
which of those waves you touch in so if
you can start to realize
that your thoughts do you think are your
thoughts there's nothing unique about
your thoughts they've been around for
thousands of years
you're just tapping into them because of
what you're doing with your body that
makes you either fearful or passionate
or courageous or whatever you're feeling
as you go in those states you get
different thoughts so what i want people
to see is that
learn how to just see those thoughts go
by learn how to be entertained by those
thoughts because i have crazy thoughts
and
but what i've gotten good at is going
look at that crazy thought that's not me
that's
the mind not your mind because if it's
you how do you change you
pretty hard but i really truly know
there's
i haven't heard a thought come out of
you that's original
you call them your thoughts but they're
not you've stolen them
name it around forever when you see that
it's easier to let go of them
and letting go of those thoughts is one
of the ways that you free yourself and
then again the more you do it just like
a muscle
you get better and better and better and
all of a sudden the [ __ ] used to make
you crazy or stressed out and like how
many things have you worried about
that never came to be and some people
their life is good so they worry about
other people
you know so they're never not worried
right so it's really just a pattern if
you want wealth
real wealth is not just money it's
emotion
it's like what are we really after money
you don't want money you want pieces of
paper with the
pictures the deceased notables on it you
want we think money will give you think
it'll give you freedom or security or
stability
or love it won't give you love it'll get
you sex it won't get you a lot of money
won't right
so really what you're after is the
emotion and so what i want people to get
is the emotion they want now and all it
is is a new habit
it's learning to discipline this mind
right
by realizing the mind thoughts are out
there
and letting them float by and constantly
coming back to what can i love about
this what can i appreciate it's like
if you can learn to love or at least
appreciate
start to enjoy the things that you used
to get upset about
how much freedom would you have how much
more joy you'd have and i know people
got billions of dollars i've coached
them
who's like holy [ __ ] they live in
scarcity all the time one man i'll never
forget he's
screaming at his wife i'm in the media
i'm in i'm in the house and he's
screaming at his wife because she spent
some money on a bunch of outfits and
stuff like that
he's a multi-billionaire he couldn't
spend all his money in his lifetime and
then he's
totally upset at his daughter who's in
her 20s who spent some money too and i'm
like i pulled him aside afterwards and i
said
what do you do this for and what do you
do it for and he's like well it's just
it's the principle thing i said no the
principle thing is do you love these
people and do you want them to have an
abundant life when you have
there's you don't have one loss but you
live like you're poor
you know and it's like i finally got
through to them but so many people
that's why i say money doesn't change
you money magnifies who you are
so you want to expand the depth of who
you are and free yourself from suffering
by just knowing it's a pattern of
thought and you can change the pattern
of thought
rule number two do it anyway with mel
robbins
do it anyway is a mindset trick that you
can use
when you start to feel excuses rolling
up it works a lot like the five-second
rule
so you have said to yourself okay i'm
gonna talk to my boss today
about that thing that i've been avoiding
talking to them about
or maybe you've said something like i'm
going to go to the gym today
or tomorrow or whatever and then the
moment comes where you've got to have
that conversation
or the moment comes where it's time to
pack up your bag
and leave your desk and go to the gym
and what always happens you don't feel
like it
i bet there are plenty of you watching
that have made a commitment that
i'm not going to have a drink tonight
and then guess what happens when you get
home
you don't feel like not drinking you
feel like having a drink
and so here's what do it anyway has done
for me
the idea that i just do it anyway
has pushed me to realize and to
recognize that there are a lot of
moments where there are things in my
life that i really
want to do i need to do
i should do but when the moment comes
i don't feel like it and so i pull out
this
idea of you know what i'm just gonna do
it anyway it's raining outside i said i
would go for a short run
i don't feel like it i'm gonna do it
anyway
it's six o'clock in the morning i'm
tired
it's cold i laid out my yoga clothes but
now i don't feel like it what do i do i
do it
anyway when you start to say to yourself
i'm going to do it anyway what happens
is something really cool
you acknowledge that there are feelings
that you have
that are trying to swoop in and hijack
you
you acknowledge them and you basically
say guess what
i'm gonna do it anyway rule number three
train your subconscious mind with john
assaraf
this is going back sometimes i think in
1992 we were stuck
but i knew there was more possibility
there was there was room for
growth and i wanted to figure out
if the stuff that i did in the 80s when
i was a kid you know that broke free
would it work with some of my agents and
so we took
75 agents randomly agents said hey do
you want to get into a six-month program
to like retrain your brain your
subconscious brain
around your beliefs about what is
possible for you to achieve
around your habits of what you have to
do in order to achieve that
and we focused on retraining their
subconscious mind
and so for six months they had to go
through a process of listening to
certain audio tapes
reading reading certain materials every
day and following the process of
training their brain specifically their
subconscious brain
which controls 95 to 98 of all of our
thoughts emotions and behaviors today
and within six months that group
increased sales by
100 million dollars jesus
100 million dollars i said holy [ __ ]
right this is working
uh and so we started to teach some of
what we teach now in neurogym actually
now we have the technologies we have the
systems that are
far better than what we did back in the
90s and we went from 1.2 billion to 4.5
billion a year and it wasn't because we
taught them any more
skills to be real estate agents we
taught them how to change the way they
thought about themselves we taught them
how to
change their habits our agents who made
750 000
or more were in front of a client 75
percent of the time
and we asked all the agents that weren't
in front of more clients like
why are you doing that like why aren't
you in front of people
that are gonna help you earn more income
oh well we're busy doing this and doing
this and doing this and they had stories
and excuses and reasons why
and so part of the work that i love to
do now is is really help people
understand
what is your story like what's the story
you're telling us
because we all have a story we have a
money story a relationship story a
health story
we have a story for everything and then
that story keeps recreating our lives
over and over and over again and we have
beliefs that support the story we have
habits that support the story we have
people that support the story we have
systems that support our story
and so my question i always ask people
who would you be with a different story
hey this is john asraf and do you love
good books i love to read because
there's so much wisdom
in books you get to take somebody else's
knowledge
skills research pay 15 20 bucks
and you learn so much now i'm reading
this
awesome book called built to serve find
your purpose and become the leader you
were born to be
and one of my new friends really smart
guy
really great guy who serves a lot of
people evan carmichael
wrote it and i'm going to read a little
bit from
chapter number one and
i love this piece and maybe it's because
i just watched
the series on tv on michael jordan the
last dance which is really great by the
way also but
one of the things he says here is
everybody has
michael jordan talent
at something everybody has a michael
jordan talent at something
you just haven't found it yet or you
have and you don't
believe in yourself enough to go
all in to go all in right
and you're a genius i believe you're a
genius and so does he
you're amazing you were not meant to
live a photocopy
of someone else's life you were not
created to wake up and do work that is
below your capabilities
you have michael jordan level talent add
something
and you need to uncover exactly what
your purpose is
and how you can serve and use the serve
so
lots of pearls and gems and motivational
pieces
pick pickup built to serve evan
carmichael
rising star rule number four observe
your thoughts with joe dispenza
i think uh you know if we everything
starts with a thought
i mean everything that you do in your
life you you have to have a thought
before you initiate an action right so
so if you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
like
any great leader in history understands
that
the first thing you have to do is you
have to decide are you going to be
defined by a vision of the future
or are you going to live by the memories
of the past so
give you an example most people wake up
in the morning
and your brain is a record of the past
it's an artifact of everything you've
learned and experienced
to this moment right it's a it's a
memory bank so
most people wake up in the morning and
they start thinking about their problems
and those
problems are connected to certain people
and things at certain times and places
and the moment they start start turning
on those circuits
those memories are actually causing them
to think
in the past every single one of those
memories has an emotion associated with
them and emotions are the end product of
past experiences
so then the moment they recall the event
or the
they recall some problem in their life
they start feeling unhappy they start
feeling discouraged they start feeling
anxious
now thoughts of the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and how you think and how you
feel creates your state of being so we
could say then
most people's entire state of being when
they start their day is in the familiar
past
well if you live in the familiar past
then it makes sense you're going to
create the predictable future
so what happens for most people is they
get stuck in their biology so think
about this
your body is your unconscious mind it
doesn't know the difference between an
experience in your life that creates an
emotion
and an emotion that you can create by
thought alone so if you're living by the
same emotion every single day and those
emotions are influencing your thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel or feelings have become the means
of thinking
you're thinking in the past your lens of
the future
is going to be colored by the past so
you can't see possibilities so
most people like to wait for crisis or
disease or diagnosis before they wake up
enough to see well the challenge is is
that biology tends to be redundant so
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
and those thoughts
begin to fire certain circuits in your
brain
the nerve cells that fire together wire
together so all of a sudden you start
getting hardwired
and those are the thoughts that you can
think the easiest at the same time
those thoughts produce chemicals called
emotions and the next thing you know
your body gets accustomed to living by
the same emotions and it could be guilt
it could be unhappiness it could be pain
but at least it's familiar to you at
least you can predict it so
some people would rather cling to the
familiar than take a chance in
possibility so
for most people then they say well i
don't really see how my thoughts have
anything to do with my destiny well
that's because
95 of those thoughts are subconscious
programs right so you're not even
conscious that you think those thoughts
so
the first step to change is starting to
think about what you've been thinking
about
and change it and and then when you
begin to observe those thoughts you're
no longer the program you're the
consciousness observing just simply by
being an observer of your thoughts right
so
so though so most people though when
they when you do that when you decide to
really take a look it's like lighting a
match in a dark place
so you feel uncomfortable so it's easier
to turn on your tv it's easier to
play with your cell phone to distract
yourself from those feelings well
when you understand that change really
requires becoming uncomfortable to a
certain degree and that's normal that
you're leaving the known and you're
stepping into the unknown
then it begs the question what thoughts
do you want to fire and wire in your
brain because
your attention on those thoughts begins
to reorganize circuitry
re-mold the brain rule number five
change your state with jim quick
you have so much intelligence in your
body right now i'll prove it to you
jump up and down a little bit and make a
little fate make a little space for the
person next to you if you can
so if you went like this you're ideally
not going to take anyone's eye out or
anything like that
okay now stop stop bouncing
i love the energy though notice where
your feet are i want you to keep your
feet stationary the entire time
and what i want you to do is with your
right hand just point forward with your
right hand
your other right hand sir sorry
i know all right forward with your right
hand and what i want you to do is i'm
moving it without moving your feet just
turn to your right clockwise
as far as you go and notice where you're
pointing
as you take your neighbor's eye out
notice how far you go notice where
you're pointing
notice the exact spot come back center
now put your arms down
now i'm going to take you through a
really quick visualization exercise
so take a deep breath exhale
and close your eyes put your arms by
your side out of your pockets by your
side
and breathe normally and with your eyes
closed
we're going to play a game i want you
just to imagine
just imagine that you're raising your
arm again
but this time imagine you're turning
twice as far
two times as far like you're getting a
good stretch
it's pleasant feel that in your body and
if you can't imagine it
just imagine that you're imagining it
and then again raise your arm point
forward and this time no no with your
eyes closed
imagine just imagine just imagine
just in your mind see and feel yourself
turning three times as far
just feel it in your body with your arms
by your side just imagine turning around
three times
and then one more time with a smile on
your face thinking what does this have
to do with learning faster
see and feel yourself turning four times
around in your body
see and feel yourself turning four times
around like your gum be like you're made
out of rubber
great great stretch all right open your
eyes
now raise your arm again point forward
with your right hand and now turn to
your right now
as far as you can now go
wow raise your hand or make some noise
if you want further second time
have a seat have a seat now some of you
went
further some of you went 25 further some
of you went 50
further yes raise your hand if you went
further a second time
now here's the magic question right that
you know i'm going to ask you
even before i ask it were you physically
capable
of turning that far the first time
like nobody took a yoga class and my
eyes were closed right
you're physically capable of it where
was the block or the limitation if there
was one
where was it in your mind right
in your mind and you're like jim i
didn't have a belief on how far i could
turn
how many beliefs do you think we have
millions and zillions of beliefs right
because here's what you want to write
down
all behavior is belief driven
all behavior is belief what
some of you went 25 50 further
with no anything remember vision was
talking about how it's not just
it's not working hard but it's you when
you're in a certain state
a mind you could just go further and
it's effortless how many people
have experienced this state of flow
before that's data flow where you lose
track of time where your attention is
right there and you're in the moment and
it's the your level of challenge is
really matching your level of
capabilities and you're stretching
yourself and you're in that zone right
like
that athletes talk about that stephen
toddler talks about in the rise of
superman and stealing fire and so on
how many people are familiar with
steve's work by the way i'm just curious
as context
okay so how do you get into those states
one of the ways is just believing that
you can
because if you believe you can or
believe you can't either way you're
right because all behavior is belief
driven
some of you went 25 50 or more what if
you could go 25 50
more in your business that effortless
what if you could go 25 50 even more
in your body or in your relationship
did you work harder the second time when
you turn the second
time yes or no no because it's a state
and rule number six the last one before
a very special bonus clip is hack your
brain with marissa peer
people think the brain is really
complicated it's not it's actually quite
simple you need to know three things
about your brain to always get what you
want and the first thing is your brain
does exactly what it thinks you
want it to do because it listens to
everything you say so when you say
things like oh god you know i got dumped
it was so painful
i never want to go through that again
all your mind can pick up is you you
don't want to be in a relationship again
when people have a miscourage and go i
could never never go through that again
i'd rather die than go through that
again your mind is picking up oh right
well that's
that's a statement that's actually a
command to me to make sure you never go
through a miscarriage again
and that that's how you get unexplained
infertility
which is something else i've been
working on a lot recently
because the mind listens to what you see
people go oh i went on this fly i
thought i was going to die
and do it again i'm never going to play
if this plane lands i will never
ever get on a plane again and of course
it lands like oh it's just turbulence
but next time they go to the airport
have a massive panic attack because your
mind's like hang on a minute
you said i never want to fly again
and so if you haven't got what you want
it's because you're giving your mind
very confusing messages your mind's
number one
job is to listen to what you say to
interact on it his second job is to move
you towards
pleasure and away from pain and it will
always always always do more to avoid
pain so let's imagine you've
gone for an interview you've done a
public speech thing
like me and you've stood up you've gone
and said oh my god i'm never doing this
again and you'd have a terrible
presentation and one of my clients who
worked for sony was saying that she had
to stand up just say to sony
this is a new band from camden and she
stood up and went this is a new band
from
and they're called uh i couldn't do it i
just
was the simplest thing and my boss had
to take over
and i was explaining to her that when
you do that and go oh my god
i don't want to do it i don't want to do
this again your mind is now going to
make sure you don't do it again so the
next time you go to speak it will give
you a panic attack
or make you ill and if you say to
yourself oh my god i'd love a week off
in bed or
i'm dreading next wednesday your mind is
so in tune with you your week off in bed
you wake up with a flu and your mind's
like there you go
how cool am i there's your week in bed
you don't want to go to that speech
i've woken you up with diarrhea so now
you can't go
that's what the mind does when i was
giving my first ever presentation
about my first ever book i woke up with
the most excruciating mic i've ever had
one before i thought wow
i must have been saying to myself so i
don't want to do this
because i've got this migraine and i
actually went and did it and i didn't
have the migraine until i stepped back
off the stage again
and i realized that i'm was
communicating very badly with myself
so you must never say nervous say
excited because your mind listens so
those three things are
your mind does what it really thinks you
want to do if you're very very specific
and so i want this
and this i want to be a great speaker i
want to deliver things i want to be
fantastic at sales i want to be able to
look through
lines sell them things and come across
as really authentic
your mind will understand and if you
make those pictures
really good and pleasant you'll move
towards them
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of
action for the next week when you watch
something and get motivated
and just get inspired you have a 35
chance of actually following through but
when you
get motivated and then you actually
create an action plan for what you're
gonna do
you increase it from 35 percent to 91
chance of you actually following through
and when you share your plan publicly
that jumps to 95 chance of following
through so i want that for you
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you you are staying small because you're
afraid
you're afraid of the worst case scenario
coming true losing
having no money and being embarrassed
but you know you're capable of more
you know the way that you're going about
doing things right now
is nothing compared to what you're
capable of
unless you lose that scarcity mindset
you're always going to stay small
knowing that you are capable of more
today i'm going to show you how
so one of the easiest ways to get out of
your scarcity mindset is to go from idea
to action as soon as you get an idea you
do
something about it and sometimes that
idea often that idea is going to be
too big too scary too crazy you can't do
it who are you to do this you don't have
the money resources time connections
energy
right all of that all of the excuses are
coming into your head i like to teach
myself that as soon as i get an idea i
go do something
it may not work but you have genius
ideas trust him go do something
[Music]
if you want to know how to get more
discipline check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there discipline discipline
discipline discipline discipline
discipline discipline discipline
discipline discipline
you